malgré tous les efforts déployés pour
promouvoir l'activité physique il faut
se rendre à l'évidence le message passe
mal
plus du quart de la population mondiale
ne bouge pas suffisamment soit la même
proportion qu'il y avait un temps qui
est intéressant c'est de voir que les
pays qui sont moins fortunés bouge plus
que les pays qui sont plus riches encore
une fois qu un lien à faire avec la
technologie
cette technologie là qui nous y
mobilisent malgré nous l'étude regroupe
des données de 2 millions d'individus
dans 168 pays
résultat plus de 27% de la population
mondiale ne fait pas cent cinquante
minutes d'exercice modéré par semaine on
observe parfois d'énormes écarts entre
certains pays est en général un fossé
marquée entre pays pauvres et pays
riches dans les pays riches peut être
que les gens sont un peu plus paresseux
dans ce sens qu'ils prennent le loto
plus ouvrir certaines portes
c'est tellement plus confortable devant
mon ordinateur ou de mourir
une autre statistique étonnante les
femmes sont moins nombreuses
atteindre le seuil minimal d'efforts et
différences culturelles
le docteur je nous crois que l'étude
surestiment le véritable effort fourni
par les participants qui ont répondu à
un questionnaire sur une base volontaire
d'après statistique canada ce n'est pas
30 % mais 50 % des canadiens qui ne font
pas assez d'activité physique
la seule chose qui qui sont identiques
qui nous donnait canadienne sait qui a
aucune amélioration ou presque depuis le
début des années 2000 pour améliorer la
situation il faudra faire plus de
promotion de l'effort physique
je pense qu'on devrait mettre beaucoup
plus d'efforts qu'elle soit on le fait
par exemple pour le tabagisme ont
déployé les gros moyens
qu'est ce qui est arrivé les niveaux de
deux fumeurs ont diminué de 10 pour sas
a eu un effet sur la longévité dix pour
cent des citoyens plus en forme
c'est précisément la cible que s'est
fixé l'organisation mondiale de la santé
si 2025 ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal